it was the night before shooting and all
through the set not a teamster was
working or breaking a sweat the director
arrived his blood was a boiling not any
director but christopher nolan where are
my actors to film my movie where's leo
where's christian where is tom hardy
but don't you know sir a pa replied it's
christmas eve sir in bed they still lie
christmas is cancelled now bring me my
screenplay bring me my actors my dp my
latte
the screenplay arrived it was 300 pages
every word genius was one for the ages
the actors arrived with a mumble and
grumble their makeup was smeared and
half drunk they did stumble
are you okay mate asked hardy with grace
you know the rules tom now cover your
face
[Music]
big tom asked again
i've been inspired said chris to his
friend
picture a man who's emotionally dead
who's trapped in a puzzle that's all in
his head
sounds like memento who might be
inception
this one is different don't doubt my
direction
he turned on his cameras all custom for
imax
look at the detail he said as he
climaxed now act like i told you your
mother just died
there shouldn't be hard
bail gruffly replied
they knocked out the scene in a take on
19 till tommy did wonder if this was a
dream
of course it is tom the order said
pissed
you know by now there's always a twist
it's christmas eve tom you're sleeping
in your bed with nightmares of nolan
dancing through your head
big tommy woke up and regained his
perceptions
then nolan popped out you're still
dreaming inception
tom finally woke and the gimmick was
done
tom secret twin told him that twist
sounded dumb
at least i'm not trapped in a cosmic
bookshelf and the power of love lets me
talk to myself
so to all his fans who think only they
get it and by get it i mean getting
kovid at tenet
merry christmas to all of you fanboys i
baited
nolan is great but he's still overrated
[Music]
you